I'm a Hitler's hated as a scam is not
Hitler Hitler springtime for Hitler he
was the ringleader old are both that
names died out on it they killed that
day at noon
no one's cooling their kid that Adolph
nowadays no little adults going to
school loads of Brad and Angelina's but
know that you don't hear the teacher
doing the register Brad here Angelina
here Adolf here I do that quick so then
one can take a picture of me doing that
no but people make excuses for him
people say oh he was stupid he was
easily led didn't he didn't mean that
what do you mean he didn't mean that
okay oh no he's influenced by the
political philosopher Friedrich
Nietzsche right because Nietzsche wrote
this paper I'm talking about a Superman
he said not all men are born equal
and Hitler misinterpreted this and went
way too far with it and think of that
you're a great scholar you've done this
work and you get a call from the Fuhrer
and if you're goes alright Nietzsche yes
yeah good what do you want because I
just read your book what do you think
love it love all that Man and Superman
not everyone's equal kill all the Jews
sorry
[Applause]
not everyone's equal so kill all the
Jews I didn't like that I read between
the lines I I didn't mean now that's
terrible you y'all been given it yep
y'all been killing Jewish people have
you what I've even in Jewish people yeah
[Applause]
a few how many six million six million
that's what I won't do anymore leave it
leave it at six that's terrible I won't
do any more stay for dinner well I will
but be careful in future I will are you
writing any other books well I am but
I'm scared to tell you about it I won't
do anything
what's a new book called my new book is
called the gypsies do we need them there
is one country that worries me though
not Iraq that Iran that North Korea the
only country that really worries me is
the country of Germany I don't know if
you guys are history buffs or not but
in the early part of the previous
century Germany decided to go to war and
who did they go to war with the world
has never been tried before and so you
figure that would take about five
seconds for the world to win but it was
actually close
[Applause]
then about then about 30 years pass and
Germany decides again to go to Oran
again it chooses as its enemy the world
and this time they have that guy got it
kinda leave that guy
I'm guys are gonna dignify it by saying
his name but I think you know I've done
but you think at that point the world
will go listen Germany here's the deal
you know you be a country no more on
encounter you keep attacking the world
[Applause]
for your Mars
I don't like arguments some people like
to argue you know they think it's like
an art I don't like it I think it's
because really ordinary arguments can
get really dramatic really quickly like
I was talking to a friend recently and I
told him that I didn't think I believed
in the death penalty and my friend said
to me oh so you're telling me that if
you saw Hitler walking down the street
you wouldn't kill him that wasn't what I
was telling you but all right let's talk
about this entirely new topic what would
I do if I saw Adolf Hitler just walking
down the street well first off I wanted
to know what did my friend mean did he
mean that I see a guy in like the
military outfit with the little mustache
because then I would assume that that
someone dressed as Hitler I'm not gonna
kill that guy I'm not gonna kill an
actor and ruin Indiana Jones 5 just cuz
I don't understand costumes what does he
mean that I'm walking down the street
and I see like an old old man who I
think might be Hitler based on my memory
of what Hitler looks like I'm not gonna
kill that guy either because I am often
wrong
I'd murder him and then people would run
up and be like wow you just killed an
old old man and I'd be like he looked
like Hitler and they're like yeah a
little look all I'm saying is wars have
been started over agree Isis great asses
caused a lot of problems a lot of wars
and you know Cleopatra Helen of Troy who
else um
Hitler Hitler had agree ask okay let's
see where that goes
no Hitler Hitler did have a great ass
it's an unpleasant fact of history but
we have to face it
many of the Nazis had great asses due to
the marching that's what it was a tone
for your buns are so firm one tight what
is your secret oh you know just diet and
goose-stepping this is my thing
[Applause]
all fields to burn oh that's when you
know it's working I don't know that many
Nazis did that but maybe they should
have good ol Nazis that's what I say
that's a phrase you don't hear often
good old Nazis
no listen NASA's are very useful if
you're in my line of work because you
know it's the one group of people you
can really [ __ ] stick it to it nobody
cares like no matter why I say but Nazis
it's very unlikely I'm gonna got a
letter or a tweet or an email tomorrow
for something saying dear Craig I am a
Nazi one time very absurd it's this
negative stereotyping of Nazis because
even if you are not seeing I've upset
you [ __ ] you you're a nothing
even even the neo-nazis the NiO of
course means you the neo-nazis yeah yeah
yeah well what's new about you why are
we march up and down and we hate ethnic
minorities that's not [ __ ] you that's
the same as the old Nazis you want to be
a noona so you got to bring something
new to the party bedazzled that swastika
mister
let's see some heels in those jack boots
I got it because these guys definitely
got scopes
no Nazi Nazis are just useful if you do
what I do because you know there's only
two groups of people you can talk about
with any degree of safety everyone else
is very very touchy and I don't mean
touchy like mr. Magoo goon that used to
live next door to me but I have to care
[Applause]
as rate laughing my pain you bastard and
click I've got some change in my pocket
he's a lovely man
now everyone is very very sensitive
everyone's very very you can't talk
about anyone there's only two groups of
people you can talk about with any
degree of safety Nazis and Canadians
that's it
Nazis go circus a [ __ ] of you upset
Nazis and Canadians because Canadians
have figured out they're very smart they
figure buddy have realized it's a
[ __ ] joke
Canadians are like oh yes that's right
it's our [ __ ] job to be honest
Canadians are just happy to be included
this is like he's talking about us I
know I know we're on our way
no I'm kidding I'm not comparing Nancy's
the Canadians and not the same at all
not since fastest Canadians lovely
lovely people Canadians a gentle
civilized beautiful people till you give
him a hockey stick then you lose the
[ __ ] mind
I don't know why the Canadian Army ball
those were tanks and guns and bombs and
[ __ ] you should just give the guys
hockey sticks and go there they are boys
the Taliban have the puck you know I
read somewhere that Hitler had a
grandson who was a convicted child
molester imagine being the embarrassment
to the Hitler family is there anything
worse than being the Hitler who the
other Hitler's don't talk about you know
I read Mackenzie Phillips autobiography
in her book she says when she was a
little girl her father would climb into
bed with her every night and have sex
with her this to me was mind-boggling I
can't get my daughter to hold my hand we
cross the street
we're running through one coming traffic
trucks are whizzing past and she's
pulling away from me
and this guy's nailing his daughter
every night I don't know how he does it
I figure II just that's more confidence
than I do and I'm not saying I want my
daughter to have sex with me I just want
her to know that Barbie Dreamhouse
wasn't free you could show some
appreciation he's one of those guys who
just makes you hate him because you know
we have a friend that you hate you can't
break up with your friends you know he
always starts conversations that I don't
want to have you know he's like hey what
would you do if you had a time machine
[ __ ] you you know what I wouldn't use it
I just let it sit my house I put a drink
on it yeah it's a machine I never you
wanted it not interested I'd use it to
go back at 30 minutes ago and punch you
in the [ __ ] face before you ask me
that that's all one use
so he goes well here's what I would do
because of course that's the whole
[ __ ] point of asking me is to stare
at me while I say my and then head say
his so he said if he had a time machine
he would have killed Hitler like he
would go back and kill Hitler I love
that he thinks he could just kill Hitler
just cuz he just goes back there and
walk up and kill the dude and I was
thinking that's a noble purpose for a
time machine I would do it but I would
have gone back then but I I wouldn't
have killed Hitler I would have raped
him that's what I thought because I
think that would have been enough I
think that would have stopped him from
doing all that [ __ ] if he had been raped
by me he never would have pulled any of
that stuff man
should we invade Poland no just take a
shower I don't feel
low self-esteem and you know
not condoning rape obviously you should
never rape anyone unless you have a
reason like you want to [ __ ] somebody
they won't let you in which case option
do you have no LCA
supposed to have an orgasm in their body
if you don't rape oh man what the [ __ ]